I've been thinking about the world
couple of Brady and then I was reminded
of this really incredible goal that just
turned a little bit over 20 years old
and it was a goal that Roberto Carlos
from the Brazil national team scored on
France in preparation for the World Cup
20 years ago one of the most incredible
goals in history it was a free-kick that
didn't seem like it was very dangerous
you know he needs to take a shot from
really really far away and he had this
incredible ability with free kicks we
went like it was just going way out of
bounds and then occurred the last moment
and and went inside players can usually
do this with the inside of the foot but
to do it with the outside of the foot
and have it curled that much is
something that I had never seen and I
don't think anybody else had before yeah
we're gonna have to see later I was
looking at all footage and they were all
this article celebrating the goal and
and I was noticing a discrepancy these
articles didn't agree on how far he was
from the goal so some articles talked
about how he was 35 meters away others
talked about how he was 35 yards away
that's not the same thing and then you
got me thinking how do we figure out how
you know nowadays we watch these games
and they automatically tell us how far
the ball is but but how do we figure
that out and I found that it's a lot
harder than I thought and so I wanted to
talk to you about about how we can do
this and and looking at this still of
the of the photograph of Roberto Carlos
his goal
I want us to just look at this and
figure out how far he was so this is
Roberto Carlos then the end goal is a
little bit hard to see but is right here
so so the goalkeeper from your birthday
is standing in front of it this right
here is the edge of the penalty box and
then this one is is sometimes called the
goal box for the goal area the point is
that we basically want to figure out
okay you know here here are these three
lines and here's the ball and with that
information how do we determine how far
the ball is from the end line maybe I
will try to draw a picture of the the
box you can't do this and I put the
penalty kick down over there although we
can't use it because you see it's not in
the photo so we're not gonna be able to
use it as a point of reference having
drawn the dog where the penalty kick is
taken there's also a little arc right
here that it's actually a circle
centered here it's an arc
Circle Center right there I wanna do
that there was a circle Center and the
idea is that when you take the penalty
kick you're supposed to be 915 away from
the from where the penalty kick is taken
and so the players cannot stand inside
that circle so that they're that far
away from it right so here we see we see
a little part of that arc which some
people call the D and what we'll see if
we need it
Roberto Carlos is out here somewhere and
we're trying to figure out exactly where
he is at least how far he is and so the
distance that we're trying to figure out
is basically from here to the end line
and here there's some things that are
worth pointing out one thing that I find
fascinating about soccer fields is that
they're not all the same size but the
boxes are all be the same size and I
hope you'll forgive me that I'm going to
do it in metric system because that's
those are the numbers that I'm used to
so in Spanish we call the little box las
Cinco cones in quinta because this is 5
meters and a half and sometimes in
Spanish we call this one la la if you
say it's consequent
like this con cincuenta because that's
how that's how long it is 60 meters and
a half what we want to do is somehow
figure out how to go from from this
picture to this picture and right away
we see an obstacle which is that the the
wall is in the way and so we actually
don't know how to draw this green line
because the wall is blocking where you
know the reference points and so the
only thing that we're able to do is draw
a diagonal line it's as if we were gonna
kick the ball and we actually need to
avoid the wall and draw a diagonal that
will go from the way the ball is sitting
to I don't know somewhere precisely the
issue is that because this is a
photograph that distorts angles when we
have a right angle here that's not a
right angle in the picture and so we
actually don't really know exactly where
the 90 degree here's one thing that that
we might try to do we might try to say
okay since we have to draw a skew line
over here then we should probably draw
it over here oh so let me draw it over
here and I think that the first thing
that I would try to do is I might say
okay well if this distance right here 16
and 1/2 and then this distance right
here is what I'm trying to find let's
call it X of course if I know X then the
distance from the from the ending will
be X plus sixteen point five then I
think was
that might be worth doing is seeing how
these distance is transferred to this
red line so if I draw this line right
here and this line right here it feels
like they should be related actually one
one thing that is true is that sixteen
point five divided by X is equal to this
distance divided by this distance I
think it's worth actually drawing a
little picture here to keep that in mind
because that's going to be important
parallel lines like this one in this one
they're parallel and if we draw two
lines I cross them like this one and
this one then if I measure this distance
let's say I call it a and this distance
is B and if I measure these two a prime
and this distance B Prime and as long as
these lines are parallel so I'm going to
draw this here to signify that is lines
are parallel then I'm going to get that
a over B is equal to a prime over V
Prime and so it feels like if I want to
find X and this then then I might be
able to relate it over here and the good
thing is that these distances I can try
to measure in this picture so I'm going
to try to do that I'm going to try say
okay well let's mark this point right
here and I can actually measure these
things so let me go ahead and do that
this is about seven point three long
seven point three centimeters and this
is about 4.5 centimeters so then you
might think that sixteen point five
divided by X since it's equal to this
distance divided by this distance you
might think that that should be equal to
four point five divided by seven point
three and then you could use that
equation to solve X except it doesn't
and and why doesn't it make sense
because there's a change in perspective
because here in in this picture I'm
looking at the field from on top whereas
here I'm looking at it from the front
and when I do that if I look at it in
this way it's it's like when you when
you walk in a room that has a square
grid of tiles and the ones that are
closer to you look bigger than the ones
that are farther than from you even
though they're the same size and so we
have the same issue
here that this part over here actually
looks bigger than it really is
and so what we need to figure out is how
does a change of perspective change
measurements and and this is an
interesting thing because this is a very
very classical problem in geometry and
and was first developed when artists and
geometers were trying to figure out how
to draw in perspective and and it's a
little piece of geometry that has been
somewhat forgotten actually I think we
should talk about it we have a green
line and a red line and then the
question is if I'm standing right here
how do how do the distances in the green
line transporter distances on the red
line so if I try to draw a picture like
the one that I drew back here except now
the lines are not parallel they meet at
that point then the question is how does
this distance and this distance relate
to this distance and this distance and
the trouble is they don't there's
there's no relationship between them no
matter what two distances you choose
here you can choose that a place to put
this line so that you can get any other
two distances here there's no relation
between these two numbers and these two
numbers and what the classical geometers
figured out is that you actually need an
additional line we're going to introduce
an additional line I made it very close
what they figured out is that now if you
look at this number over here so if I
call this distance a this distance B and
this distance C and I call this little
distance a and this distance B and this
distance C then the question is how are
these related it turns out that the
answer is this beautifully mysterious
thing where if you take four points like
these four points and maybe I'll call
this a point a B C and D then there's
something called the cross ratio what
you do is that you compute the distance
AC you compute the distance BD you
multiply them and then you divide by the
distance BC and the distance ad I think
this is a totally weird thing to do
that's the cross ratio why do we do this
because it turns out that this is the
quantity
that is preserved by a change of
perspective so if I compute this
quantity on my red points I'm going to
get the same answer as if I compute that
quantity on my green you can imagine for
example one way of thinking about this
is that if I look at this picture you
might think that you know this is a
projector and this is a wall and so if
you're trying to project the movie and
you a new angle the protector
differently then you're distorting the
picture in the wall and as you know some
things become bigger some things become
smaller and the question is what doesn't
change and it turns out that the one
thing that doesn't change is it's a
cross-racial it's it's a very strange
thing but that's the thing that is going
to allow us to compute Roberto Carlos is
ago because this is just a change of
perspective between the angle of the
camera and and the angle from the from
the sky and so we can just compute the
cross ratio and these two pictures and
get that it should be fixed and we'll
figure out the distance one thing you
might notice we don't have enough
information now because to compute the
cross ratio we need four points and here
when we were looking at these lines at
the green line that we're trying to
compute we only had we were only paying
attention to where Roberto Carlos is and
this point and this point we're missing
a fourth point okay now luckily the
soccer field have the cinco qin
cincuenta box the call box and so we're
going to use this point right here this
sixteen point five meters splits up into
5.5 here or six yards and 11 here and so
now what I'm going to do is take instead
of these four green points I can take
this one this one this one and this one
and then because of this property right
here these ratios the red ratios are the
same as the green ratios and so one
thing that I can do is just say that the
the scaling from here to here is a
constant C and that means that if this
is five point five then this distance
right here is five point five times C
this one if this is eleven then this
distance is eleven times C
and if this is X then this is X times C
and so we're going to be computing the
cross ratio over here which means that
we should come and measure it over here
in our furrow of the Roberto Carlos goal
so now I'm going to consider this point
right here so that I can have four
points to compute my cross ratio and so
now this distance over here was four
point five and so now we should figure
out how much is this and how much is
this now I can make a wrong guess the
wrong guess is that you know in the real
picture this is twice this and so I
might get oh then this would be twice
this it should be three and one point
five but we talked about how in this
picture these distances are look longer
they're closer to you so I think when I
measure this I should get that this
should be bigger than two times this
there's our distortion there so let's
take out the ruler and measure it one
point three and so as I just discussed
that this should be more than twice this
and so now we can compute the the cross
ratio for these four points and for
these four points and I should get the
same answer so why don't we go ahead and
do that this formula tells me that I
should take this distance which is four
point five then I should take BD which
is this distance three point two plus
seven point three that's about ten point
five and divide by the small distance in
the middle which is three point two
times the big distance which is eleven
point eight so this is the close ratio
in the photo one point two five one
let's do maybe two three digits and so
that's what I can measure that's in the
photo that's the measure cross ratio now
what is the real cross ratio let's
compute it over here so first I'm
supposed to take the distance from here
to here right now that's five point five
C plus eleven C so there's going to be
sixteen point five C now I'm supposed to
compute this distance 11 C plus X C so
I'll factor out the C and I'll get 11
plus X times C and now I'm supposed to
divide this by the small distance in the
middle which is 11 C and this big
distance which is sixteen point five C
plus XC and
I'll factor out the C now one lovely
thing that happens here is that all the
C's cancel out like this cancels out
with this this cancels out with this and
so we just get something in terms of X
this is the measured cross ratio this is
the real cross ratio and then the magic
here is that these two numbers are
actually equal to each other so this is
equal to this one 81.5 plus sixteen
point five x is equal to one eighty one
point five plus 11 x times one point two
five one so that's equal to x one point
two five one equals so through value of
x all right all right so that's how far
he is from the box
so that's how far he is from the box
exactly so X is equal to approximately
16 point sixty three which if you look
at it it's actually pretty much the size
of the box right so the the box is
sixteen point five and he's sixteen
point six away so he's basically two
boxes away from the goal line and then
if we add this so that's it that's how
you do this it's pretty cool no I really
thought this was a lot easier I actually
had to I mean I'll tell you how this
happened I was teaching a gym class in
geometry and it came time to the
projected to teach projective geometry
and I learned about the conservation in
that class that I was teaching for the
first time and I thought wow this sounds
actually really powerful I've come to
love the cross ratio I think it's I
think it's a beautiful thing and I think
there's this really interesting quote by
Robin Hartshorn who is one of the
world's foremost geometers and in his
textbook when he's talking about the
cross ratio he says I must say frankly
that I cannot visualize a cross ratio
geometrically if you like it is magic
you might say it is a triumph of algebra
to invent this quantity that turns out
to be so valuable and could not be
imagined geometrically or if you were a
geometry at heart you may say that it is
an invention of the devil and hated your
whole life so dramatic note I really
like it and I think it tells the story
of how in mathematics you don't get to
choose what field you work on any you
know you think you're doing geometry all
of a sudden this very
quantity comes in and we're actually
relying on this pretty deep algebraic
fact that at least I have no geometric
intuition for and I think that's really
beautiful
the funny thing is he went for a show
and not across yeah that's right hi
everyone as usual we'd like to really
thank our patreon supporters whose names
you're seeing on the screen at the
moment these people get special access
to our patreon feed plus some of them
get special traits such as well original
Brown papers from the videos original
postcards written here at this desk
other weird bits and pieces like
numberphile dice and Parker Square
notepads plus we have a very special
trait coming later this month but more
about that in the next few weeks but
that's not fun I mean the whole point of
this is to buy stickers and trade it
with other people and so on and so I
think we should go for a little bit of a
more realistic scenario